và các bù trí giới giới giới lều tăng mạnh của chương mối cạnh xinh độ trung đong đã gây hình hồn đáng kể để nhoạt động vận tài và đời sống người dân.
Theo số liệu của bộ thương mạnh các bù trí giới giới giới và khi hoa lòng là bé cơ đã tăng lần được là bộ mi móc phy nhé phần chăm.
Chỉ biết tương phẩy tháng phần chăm, có chính phần chăm kể từ khi xung độ đủ phát.
Chỉ vì như liệu theo tháng kế nhiều xương nghiệp và tài xế phần tài, đối mạnh với ác lực tài chính hệ càng lớn.
Như còn đi lại cũng có số hiệu dạm khi ngư dân các sản kích chi tiêu khá hình ổ và mạnh rộn lĩa xung tuu của các xe phụ bộ phải thung cộng.
Chứ tình hình này chính phụ phòng chìa đốt chiến tháng với bình phát, nhằm giảm phát đau bao gồm các sản phình được khẩu đủ vỷ liệu.
Đồng thời chính xác sản thời đối xe điện và tý vị năng lượng mặt chơi.
Cũng đưa thu dầy, nhằm đa sản thoảng 1 năng lượng.
Giới trưa ra nhận đệnh nếu sản nước lượng phần cộn tức tục biến đậu.
Ninh kinh tế các mùi chia có thể chính thuyên áp lực trong thời gian tới, đều biệt trong các lĩnh vừa phụ phụ phụ phụ lớn vào chi phí phát đại.